welcome to tasties nacho cook-off three
members of the tasty team face off to
see who can make the best nachos
competing in this event are Robin Bratva
tasty video producer Hannah Williams
tasty video producer and Nick Guillory
tasty social media strategist so today
I'm making steak and potato nachos so I
made this into a video and once it was
made
I usually like to take my food home but
in this case it didn't happen because
all my co-workers ate it I've got three
russet potatoes which I'm going to
season with olive oil salt pepper and
paprika I'll bake the potatoes at 450
degrees for about 20 minutes while
that's cooking I'm going to season the
steak and get a nice sear on them
roughly three minutes each side I'll put
the steak once after that I'll let the
steak rest for 8 to 10 minutes because
it's still cooking after you take it out
of the pan once the potatoes are ready
I'm going to lay them around the
cast-iron pan and sprinkle the steak on
them when everything is assembled I'm
going to cover the dish in freshly
grated cheddar and Monterey Jack cheese
and then I'm just gonna boil it 7 to 10
minutes everything's nice and melted and
then top it off with sour cream and
salsa and serve it when I was younger I
wasn't really allowed in the kitchen my
mom would always shoo me away but then
going to college my dad said this would
be a good way to go on dates if women
knew you could cook today I'm making
Korean pork belly nachos I make a lot of
desserts for tasty I'm kind of known for
making cheesecake there's a little out
of my comfort zone so the first thing
I'm gonna do is get this pork in the
marinade it's gonna marinate in some
kimchi juice soy sauce sesame oil Korean
red pepper and honey and I'm gonna sear
it on an extremely high heat to try to
render it's got a little bit and get it
nice and crispy and while that cooks I'm
gonna dice my toppings I got some red
onion some kimchi I'm gonna layer that
on top of the pork and the chips I'm
gonna grate some cheddar and Monterey
Jack and let that melt on top of the
nachos and then my finishing touches are
gonna be some diced tomatoes and green
that's gonna go on top of everything
once it's melted and I'm gonna mix some
sour cream with kimchi juice and drizzle
that on top as a finishing touch to tie
it all together when I think of nachos I
think of kind of the standard salsa
beans cheese whatever you like on that
so this is just a really really
different type of nacho it's not too
loaded it's not too heavy but it still
has a lot of flavor hi I'm Nick and I'm
making spicy cheesy blackened chicken
nachos today these guys cook like this
all the time this is my first time like
cooking with all these cameras and these
fancy lights these microphones like I'm
not gonna lie it's good here I'm going
to season my chicken with Cajun
seasoning garlic powder chili powder and
hot sauce while that's cooking I'm going
to cut up some onions tomatoes jalapenos
and corn I'll saute those veggies with
more Cajun season I'll add the black and
chicken to the mixture and top it all
off with freshly grated pepper jack
cheese and salsa
Oriol that till the cheese is melted I'm
from Louisiana and I love spicy food I
like to entertain at home this would be
like a cute little appetizer
get everybody nice and spicy and moving
around and hot and sweaty before we go
dancing
what kind of beautiful mess is this that
I walked actually what notches are a
beautiful mess this is real crunchy it's
got a nice crunch oh nice not you I love
this but it doesn't have that classic
nacho cheese yeah it's very original
though okay well so next one
it almost functions kind of like a dip
this looks like a little bit of salsa
yellow cheese that is delicious its bite
you know no I'm not perfect ratio of
cheese steak bacon I want this so badly
there's a lotta cheese oh wait are there
no chips Johanna we all agree though if
this one had crispy potato chips it
would win for sure the flavors in this
one was on Koya mainly we're just
thankful that they made this food for us
yeah my winner
my decision is this guy mine is the
blackened chicken
mine was the blackened chicken
[Music]
Oh oh yes